kim jong-un visitó la sede nacional de
prevención de epidemias en corea del
norte a primera hora del jueves según
los medios estatales el líder del país
se reunió con integrantes del partido
del trabajo para hablar del brote de
kobe 19 en el país
su respuesta declarar el estado de
emergencia más severo y anunciar un
confinamiento nacional según los medios
de comunicación estatales varias
personas murieron y miles enfermaron con
fiebre y reconocieron que uno de los
fallecidos fue contagiado por la
variante omicron según la agencia
oficial de noticias
350.000 personas han sido tratadas por
fiebre desde finales de abril más de
180.000 norcoreanos están actualmente
aislados y en tratamiento aunque no se
ha especificado cuántos positivos por
kobe 19 ahí se cree que la mayoría de
los 26 millones de habitantes del país
no están vacunados corea del norte
rechazó las ofertas de vacunación de la
ms pero también de china y rúsia los
expertos dicen que un brote podría ser
una catástrofe
debido al cove' 19 la escasez de
alimentos y la crisis económica podrían
deteriorarse en corea del norte para
evitarlo corea del norte está llevando a
cabo medidas de racionamiento de
alimentos así que están bajo medidas de
cuarentena muy severas para prevenir un
brote masivo de casos confirmados de
kobe según los expertos el virus llegó a
corea del norte a través de una persona
que cruzó la frontera ilegalmente desde
china